It's too good,
My name is,
my name is Rima Hassan,
I am 29 years old,
I am of Palestinian origin and uh.
I am originally from the Neilab camp which
is located in the suburbs of Aleph in Syria.
I arrived in France via the family procedure.
So it is my mother who had arrived in France in
1st time by dint of an administrative procedure,
she managed to bring my 5 brothers and sisters and me.
Uh.
The arrival in France was uh.
Necessarily 1 little rough.
Uh in the early days,
but uh.
For my part,
what was uh surrounded by hum Of
connection with this new collective that was uh.
France has been uh Education Well I've been uh studying law I've been
doing international law and uh International Organization And I've uh started.
Uh,
2 short years of thesis.
Uh.
On the question of applicable law in the Refugee Caen.
So today I am rapporteur at the national court of dronazine,
So it is the court that will rule,
uh On appeals,
uh formulated against cases of decisions of love pra.
Love pra which is the French office for the protection of
stateless refugees which is the administration in France?
Who's going to uh.
Statue,
uh on asylum claims that are going to be uh.
Filed.
Uh on uh our territory.
And in parallel,
I preside over the observer of the refugee canes that was born
at 2 and a half years and that participates in raising awareness.
Uh.
Study and investigate refugee canes around the world.
It seems like we actually tend to hear that we migrate to enjoy uh.
Either from another country,
from another,
from another society,
from uh.
Of her wealth or of what she has to offer,
And we tend to forget that We also come to contribute.
So I was tempted.
Uh.
I'm really in line with that dynamic,
I feel and I'm proud of contributing to a lot of things.
Uh. In France,
perhaps also the opportunity to recall that the level of education,
so of.
Uh.
Refugees.
Uh, uh.
On the latest studies that's been done,
uh,
with the latest waves,
uh.
Migratory so uh.
In France uh have well demonstrated that these are people who uh.
Uh have 1 level of education which is sometimes higher uh than the national uh.
In reality it's people who have talents,
knowledge, uh do,
uh Who uh who are,
who just need to be put to good use of this new collective.
I'm not going to be very. Uh.
Original. Uh.
The woman who inspired me the most was my mother so uh.
Through its course of.
Uh.
Migration just all she had to.
Uhm. Uh.
Finally,
harden all the obstacles she has not done.
Uh.
Face that it's before the and Uh.
After his arrival in France,
it was uh.
1 inexhaustible source.
So much inspiration and energy and courage for everything I've done.
After This is
too beautiful.